now on to a story that you at home
brought our attention to during our
community phone bank in fact brian you
took this phone call i took this phone
call his woman says she was promised an
old pole in front of her new house would
come down victoria saha went to the
development to get her some answers
[Music]
electric poles can be found throughout
the city of las vegas but this one
stands right in front of a house the
homeowner thinks it doesn't have a
purpose and now she wants it gone which
is why she reached out to 8 news now
80 year old delores taylor has lived in
her house on la madre way and jones for
less than two years and she's already
frustrated with it but it's not her
house that's the issue it's her view
please help me get that pole down it's
this wood electric utility pole that
dolores wants gone but it just looks
terrible i spoke to three
people that were electricians and when
they looked at it they just they said
there was no electric going to that pole
delores purchased this house in 2020
after seeing a model of it by a builder
when it got closer to the time of me
closing on the house i said what about
that pole
and they
the man in the um the model said well
it'll come down you know
okay when
i couldn't get a definite date on nearly
two years later that poll is still there
they said wait until someone called you
oh and i was so happy to hear your voice
delores says she called us after she
couldn't get an answer from the builder
dr horton or envy energy if you spend as
much money as these houses were worth
you wouldn't want that ugly
pole there if you want a pole there why
don't you put a new one there delores
tells me had she known the pole would
still be here two years later she would
have never bought the house reporting
from the north valley victoria saha 8
news now